i prefer the dynamic
between
gordon and batman in this one i st but i
i still prefer gary oldman but that but
i think of gary oleman i think a lot of
like
scenes in the dark knight yeah i
have to save dent but yeah but also at
the end when he's like i'm sorry forever
yeah like that moment i i think your old
man doesn't get enough credit for it the
work he puts in yeah for the dark knight
in all three movies he's so consistent
and his arc is really subtle as it grows
and changes yeah yeah i agree is
incredible bruce wayne
also just that one
i only put a coat on one boy my whole
life
and i never got that coat back you must
be bruce wayne i've sent so many letters
to your house
i have dispatched countless officers to
wayne manor to get my goddamn coat back
i've been cold for 30 years
uh what up guys big fan we're a big fan
of yeah
i love what'd you do
i loved the arkham scene between batman
and riddler uh paul dano killing
oh
this is
not how i was supposed to go
well i think what was really triggering
is the when the the first time i watched
it i was like huh it's probably gonna be
prompted back for people and i forgot
all about it and the second time i
watched it i was like huh
i didn't remember that because it's
probably gonna be problematic for people
when they watch
you forget again when catwoman and then
sure enough it just started happening uh
like i saw it all i saw on social media
it was even the line about like these
white privileged people
she said white
privilege instead of privileged people
but she added the word
what was it strong w
[Music]
this was
[Music]
the mayor's wife and son
possibly had the worst week
first the father died and then a car
burst through in his funeral and find
the city
it's so funny they didn't think about
week and it perspective also the idea
that they just go home each night like
[ __ ] that's gotta be the worst day of my
life and then wake up
like we don't really see them
just being like oh [ __ ] and then like
the next day brothers got it out for
this kid man i've been looking forward
to this movie for the past two years and
watching campia's and your coverage of
everything batman keep up the good work
guys you keep campy out of this goddamn
conversation you hear me check his dick
robert pattinson's dick the lighting on
his dick was more of a two-face i'm just
joking
he can't be as my buddy he shouts me out
all the time on his show now i mean we
shot him up too look at this oh
i am in marvel and dc how do you do it
uh so basically
i really
i'm a marvel ndc fan
so basically what are the chances of
soups in this universe in your opinion
provided you haven't heard what matt
reeves says i would say slim to none and
that's how i like matt ramos matt ramos
in the that's right he's gonna be there
show up uh
let's go
robin here's why you should be concerned
about the riddler's plan for gotham
cook this send it to rob universe
tick-tock
i said i was
i don't want to say the s word i don't
want to bring i don't want to call them
they're like baba dukes snyder fans
they'll appear i don't hey man snyder
fans are great i don't i'm a sniper fan
i like no i'm a snyder fan i'm just not
sure
then again on tick tock i'm getting
attacked left and right because people
are like [ __ ] you this is the batman
like the snyder snyder center and like
that's why i think my animosity is not
fair because it's not the actual people
it's the vocal minority of people that
are attacking the movie because it's not
their batman but that's it's an
archetypal character like there's so
many takes not all snyder verse fans are
jerks i i just said us a vocal minority
i'm acknowledging that i was just lying
to not upset the sniders okay
what they've done for charity and
everything i respect 99
i
feel in many ways like a part of that
but i don't attack people about that
that's what i mean
yeah oh yeah we should play john
campio's live stream while
let's get it at a picture in picture
let's just be honest let's just have a
champion
let's put it in the way you don't
[Laughter]
[Music]
what are you doing
i want paul dano from riddler to go up
against willem dafoe from the lighthouse
ooh okay i want paul dano and daniel
day-lewis as harvey dent why
just spill your bees
damn whatever we need
that car chase reinvents a very obvious
choice but does it in a comic book
cinema and and that plus the roar of the
batmobile like that whole sequence had
me [ __ ] hard
yeah
it was really uncomfortable sitting next
to you now i was like bro bro look at
this [ __ ] batmobile that's what i call
him now
let's rev this engine
barracuda
giancarlo esposito should definitely be
mr freeze holy [ __ ] is that a fan
casting then that this been going around
i love that i can already see it i can
see the eyes i can't play every villain
though i like ron cephas jones as mr
freeze for me i like nick offerman as
the supers
the mustache under the dome
time to kick some ice
what killed the dinosaurs holy [ __ ] have
you done before that
is i just hear his voice some crazy [ __ ]
in the end somehow he like planted all
those explosions at the top
that was a distinction that wouldn't
fall on the crowd of people
[Laughter]
was did batman blow up the roof that's
dangerous as hell he definitely did yeah
it was like we did he planned that yeah
yeah i was like i don't know the first
time i saw it was like oh i thought that
was riddler business and then each
subsequent time i'm like no i think
that's batman but also hundreds of
people
blow the whole roof up could you just
blow like a piece of it or one pane of
glass theatricality yeah
yeah it's raining why not rain glass too
they're not enough danger drowning and
electrocuting you gotta throw some
glasses
i believe actual
i believe actual testosterone is clear
he does
that doesn't blow up that old roof here
if you look at the batman comics like
batman it's kind of huge just to land in
that one spot it's a dome it's
gigantic i need to save these people let
me flow
from the wounds that i've given them
with all this glass at least a third of
the space of the floor there
uh my only nitpick is the uh i think the
joker scene should have been post credit
i have a nitpick
no you just keep you on all right i'm
doing a live stream i got a couple small
nitpicks one uh when did he go back and
swim around for his knife oh thanks man
uh because he clearly dropped it when he
fell off the cable all right he's got a
couple probably transferred to uh
transfer the fifty thousand and uh other
nitpick and it's not really he's finally
nitpick oh yeah koi
i find it really hard to get the four
tourist studios
about the narrating parts of the story i
loved it so much and hope they keep
doing it in future movies this has been
actually i'm fascinated to see so many
people debate this point in particular
on reviews i've debate
uh people don't all love generations
shall i engage in this level of verbal
jesting today debates you say debate
where on debates point me to the podium
show me the way
where are my note cards i will fight
them yeah i think every one of these
should deal with weather
first one water the next one a tornado
no yeah the third one tornado tornadoes
and garden hurricane god journalist
kite man kite man comes in on the
tornado and he's just man in here [ __ ]
yeah dude bring me kite man i uh i think
that the only way to get sean connery
out of retirement is to have him play
kite man so i were to resurrect him
out of retirement from the mortal coil
out of retirement from existence did
sean gotery die out of retirement from
six
i thought a league league of
extraordinary job was his last movie i
thought he retired no he did sir billy
he does the scottish animated
masterpiece sir billy
i think i'm learning sean connery died
dude what was this this was a couple of
years ago no embarrassing probably more
than that now okay 2020 we were all a
little busy yeah that's fair i missed it
that's fair i was
trapped inside my house with nothing
much to do i did not know i couldn't
find it out
completely i was missing
court of owls with hush and asriel
calendar
calendar man tease oh [ __ ] this up
johnny each film i gotta catch you in my
throat
jake
uh that's a lot um i don't know if we're
gonna get 15 villains
uh but uh john's dying from the volume
of sheer villainy you've brought forth
to the batman i'm here that said this
movie did have you know a fair amount of
villains and it made them work um
but oh my god until jon comes back i'm
trying to recover it it's not working
out i'm trying so hard i like that
you've beat out a whole franchise here
and i think that that's great we should
give money
to uh an indiegogo campaign you know we
always start off
jesus christ you have two drinks over
there
injects himself with the adrenaline and
he's just unleashing all of the pain and
rage and even catwoman is like whoa dude
that you trying to calm me down and uh
even though that's not like the biggest
most picturesque moment in the movie
that was a moment where when he turns
around and he's got that wild look on
his face like he could have decked
gordon if you didn't have that one
little ounce of restraint like that that
left me pretty speechless in the moment
i got a confession to make about that
scene you don't like that scene i
actually love that scene it's one of my
favorites but when he turns around
as i
i always think of the batman from how it
should have ended
[Laughter]
every single time that's really funny it
does seem like
next time i watch like the kind of
breathing he's doing now i can't yeah i
can't be able to unsee this i've ruined
one of my favorite scenes
after he leaves the hospital with alfred
i think it's great he's just only in the
batsuit yeah
well and yeah like i can absolutely uh
respect your opinion but i i do feel
like uh there is something i know you
guys are going to live in the dark with
us for a while now i was born welcome to
the darkness molded by it
i didn't see the camera until i was a
man
favorite aspect of the movie mine was
gotham
gotham's great in this movie best
co-star in the film and that's saying
something like the the second lead of
this film is gotham and it's incredible
gotham also great supporting character
that abandoned construction site that
they meet at all the time you can't say
a movie tries to be artsy like the
lighthouse and then go gotham second
best character
this succeeds with me
so yes i can say that i also said
eternals was an artist's film because
the amount of sunsets and holding hands
i stand by my standards i believe
have you seen ben shapiro's review no
but i'll probably watch it i'm so
excited he's coming up he hates the film
he said he thinks more about the more
makes him angry the complete opposite
for me the more i think about it the
more i love it look i'm not going to lie
to you guys
i'm a hard alt-right
i love mentioning
all about that shifter the daily wires
should have made the batman all right uh
but i'd say sterling k brown would crush
sterling k brown is sorry that would be
rad because he i could see him as a d.a
i could also see him really angry i
could see him playing someone that has
like a strong world compass that's
decided like that like i think honestly
sterling k brown would be great and we'd
finally get that [ __ ] billy d
williams nod that we should have had as
harvey done
why would we get the billy d williams
because he was supposed to be harvey
knit he was supposed to be two-faced in
the third movie that tim burt never got
but why would sterling k brown be the
he's an african-american man we've never
had a so that would be a two-face that
would be a nod because he's black yeah
so
does
zaredek hard to nod tommy lee jones yeah
because he's
white no we've never had a black
toothpaste and in the comics we have and
in the movies we were supposed to so i
think it'd be nice too all right henry
goldberg
what is [ __ ] up about the timber about
what happened there that is [ __ ] up
they literally whitewashed that's like
the natural definition of white watching
everything harvey ten it was black and
then what
ring
so that's why i know you're giving me
[ __ ] but that's why i want like a black
two-face because like we were supposed
to
good call and people are always coming a
lot of people are so complaining about
the other way around you know what
surprises me every time i watch this
movie
the commissioner's voice
is so high yeah
oh my god and that one cops
also the one cops voice of the mustache
that like yeah yeah he's like
dude john we got ourselves a situation
you really trust this guy jim
it works because the movie is so
stylized but in any other movie that i
don't know that guy's got his one
the commissioner's voice always throws
me off so mickey mouse every time i saw
you in the trailer man i did not imagine
that [ __ ] boy all these weezy guys
running gotham's lawd
what's he doing here hey rob
vigilante michael that's mitchell
all right
give him the room
she's gonna get higher and higher as
this goes
as matt reeves understood that bruce and
batman is a broken person who watches
bruce wayne and thought yeah that guy is
a vigilante vengeance thoughts robert
pattinson is phenomenal in this movie
he's too skinny to be the best little
[ __ ] guy
his [ __ ] guy doesn't even do his
curves
i'm not worried about bruce's little boy
get your boy to listen to weights jim
two sizes too big that jacket is
there's no way he's the bet do you think
robert pattinson will be the type of
bruce wayne to create a matches malone
party oh this is a dope question mike k
yes i actually think of any
bruce wayne actor the one who will make
personas is the one that does not yet
have a persona like the the identity of
bruce wayne right now is the most
malleable so it'd be really cool to see
him develop the bruce wayne persona as a
playboy as well as a matches malone type
detective it's kind of like he's uh to
to people that don't know match the
moment he's kind of like patched to
logan which is probably even more
obscure reference he's a very uh he's a
well done now you got two to explain i
literally just explained something nerdy
with nerdier um he is a persona within
inside a persona as a way to uh
hone in on stuff and mislead others like
so logan with a patch on is this guy
that runs madrapore [ __ ] i'm just
getting deeper in the hole uh madrapore
is an area in mutandum where uh crime
and villainy
and madrapore is in uh a falcon in the
winter soldier and it's a it's a land a
mutant hive of another personality bruce
what's up man it's not that hard another
detective and in madrid of certain crime
elements
i
am going to have a confession here
i did not realize until it was pointed
out to me
that when he goes on to the website
i was like oh url yeah
oh you didn't catch that i was like
yeah how did you know to go on the
website like
whatever one i talked to knows that yeah
i love that because
it has a flow that's completely gone
over my head
every single time it's the only thing
that said slowly like in that whole
sequence u r
l
craig's like w-w-w
[Laughter]
because i just think of it i don't think
of the letter u that's why it's such a
good writer i know yeah i know it's i
get it uh but it's
not the world's greatest decision
i was like
i could pick up on all
down to the terminus he has to like take
his bike down the stairs
how does he get his car out
good suspension he's got
he's got it on like those low rider
hydraulics
these are the
training scene it's really [ __ ] great
just training before fighting superman
as if this training is going to do oh it
helps you in boston you're trained to
play pets from boston i know i love how
you view every boston actress their
character is from boston
even in space
bilber
everyone from boston stays from boston
it's a prerogative i think heath joker
is like up there with brando and paul
thomas i think uh
like i'm sorry what's his name papa
timer sanderson's
the actor i mentioned him earlier
he's retired now he's a cobbler
uh daniel day lewis i think like daniel
day lewis caliber performance from heath
dia de los muertos he figured it out
yeah i was just like his hands on my
shoulder that's comforting
the more i've seen this movie the more i
really am enamored with the paul danos
can you imagine they got down they lose
out to play someone played kite man
[Laughter]
that takes place in boston because mark
wahlberg is in it does it not
like uncharted they found treasure all
throughout boston yeah that's boston
harbor that's where that ship is boston
harbor
that's where america was founded i would
love to play
alfred
[Music]
alfred we need a filipino
but i wouldn't do the british accent no
of course i would just be me you're
authentic i would be my sincerest
i would just be like the way i sound
right do you know where my two-face is
from
boston
d.a a [ __ ] boston kid
they've all got to get this joker
[ __ ] [ __ ] this [ __ ] joker
kid is really [ __ ] up my business
there's no difference between harvey
he's the same [ __ ] guy he's [ __ ]
but this half's [ __ ] green because
the green monster [ __ ] fenway jones
was like he's just the same guy with a
coin just flipped a lot of [ __ ] he
occasionally talks in the wii but i flip
a coin like we flip kaz after the
[ __ ] sock sweep it kid like i thought
the one element of the burton that stuck
with me was always a batmobile now this
is taking over
that's pretty badass yeah it gets really
impressive it's pretty ba it's about
it's more efficient than that [ __ ]
one in the dark nitrogen yeah the
tumbler didn't ever work for me tumblr
seems like it's just out to destroy the
city
i will say
by [ __ ] up its infrastructure this
vehicle is designed for you to worry as
little as possible about all the
collateral damage you are about
on your city point of this car is you
can drive it over or through anything
jumping over rooftops
up is just playing robert de niro all
the time
you are just doing robert de niro you
know where colin farrell's from
original boston
[Laughter]
proto-boston
see you guys
peace out
mike drive
not ending the livestream
[Music]